a trip to the supermarket these days it
costs a lot more than it used to
customers are angry but they're also not
entirely convinced about the latest
proposal being considered by the
government a cap on the price of basic
food items I only buy own brand things
only nothing else
to me it seems very expensive you cut
back and you cut back on fuel and cut
back on everything it really has
steadily gone up rather than seeing any
difference with like even when the
offers happen it's a plan that's been
implemented in some European countries
but supermarkets in Britain say it's
unfeasible retailers make between three
and four percent margin
that's what they make and that's you
know that that if you took to compare
that against margin was made by other
Industries and let's take the energy
industry that's a completely different
that's comparing an apple and a pair
we're in a very efficient industry and
we are very competitive and you know
with a number of outlets that we've got
here now the consumer has got massive
Choice uh and uh and in real terms
fantastic value for money
the problem is customers have become
accustomed to value for money
food prices have been falling in real
terms for decades so the sudden Spike
has taken Everyone by surprise
and customers are confused as to why
prices are high even when energy and
commodities such as rapeseed oil and
wheat are falling in price
commodity prices may be coming down but
the prices we pay at the supermarket are
still stubbornly high there is of course
a lag between the two but it's fueled
speculation that retailers may be
profiteering supermarkets however are
adamant that this is not the case and
you only have to look at their profits
to see the pressure they're under
all of the big four supermarkets have
seen their profits fall significantly
over the last year many are convinced
that price caps aren't the answer so
what is it's much better to think about
the households who are really having
difficulty in meeting their food and
energy bills and targeting support to
them through Universal Credit if we
possibly can if we can rather get some
cash in the hands of those who need it
the most that's a much much more
appropriate way of government policy
being designed rather than distorting
the price mechanism
poorer families are indeed bearing the
brunt of high food prices and they're
desperate for Solutions
but are still waiting for ideas that are
actually put into practice gopreet no
one Sky News